i i think most of the a lot of lgbt
people that i know
are voting are voting red it's really
really bizarre
that's so neat and i think it's not
because they necessarily
like trump they just don't like the
progressive left like that's
really what it's and a lot of people say
that to me like is that the reason it's
like yes it's part of the reason for
sure
i want to be able to have my speech and
say whatever the hell of course exactly
you jump down my throats which has been
happening for the past six years dude
yeah i know
i don't want it getting worse exactly it
does directly affect me you know
and i think i think a lot of the
progressive left is
anti-women believe it or not no i think
you're right oh 100 i really do 100
i'm big with that the last time we
talked you and i we talked about
the progressive left actually being like
anti-lesbian like trying to
expand the definition of lesbian to
include like like all other genders
according to that give me a break and
it's so funny because i i was reading
this article that made me think of you
it was from pink news and it was talking
about how
there's only like 15 lesbian bars left
in the country
and then one of the things that said
like lesbian bars are important to
foster an environment open to all
sexualities and genders and stuff
i thought it was so funny in like the
first paragraph they're pretty much like
already racing lesbians
right yes like what the heck she's right
i'm telling you they they don't like
women they really do
they really don't and it kind of bothers
me because i'm like what are you doing
y'all are supposed to be representing
minorities you guys were supposed to be
the party that was supportive and
inclusive for women and their women's
vote and everything and you're not
you're
failing let's let's go over to the other
party until something comes up better
for us until you guys reform
it's true i've never had anybody tell me
i'm
not a real lesbian or not a good enough
lesbian on the right side
not a realist that's insanity why would
we
so weird to me if that's what they do so
i don't know it's strange i don't get it
what do you think seamus um just in
general about the left and the way that
they treat
women i mean yeah generally speaking
what the left does is they have their
own revolutionary ideas and they try to
find different groups that they can
claim to stand for
so that they can you know quote unquote
represent them really what they want is
to tear down the system and reform it
and i shouldn't say reform it rebuild it
into something entirely new
and the best way to do that is to get
people who you either foresee
perceive as being or can convince them
that they are on the outside of the
system
and then they'll fight it with you yep
yeah so
the all of the identity politics stuff
and this
goes for not just the modern iteration
of that but
going back to even just the idea of like
gay pride in general or
gays and lesbians before transgenderism
was a question
yep and even a lot of what we saw um
with
racial identity politics was very much
to get
people to revolt against the system
which existed not necessarily because
the left was interested
in the well-being of those people but
because they were interested in tearing
the system down
and we can see for some of those groups
of people there are injustices so for
example i don't think any of us would
argue that
the civil rights movement or the fact
that people were marching against jim
crow
was a bad thing of course not but i
think it's clear to see
that so much of the reason that the left
is interested
to whatever degree they try to appear to
be interested in the well-being of these
groups is just because they see them as
useful pawns exactly
and this is why you're told you're not
really black if you don't vote for
joe biden thank you or well you know
people might claim that uh
somebody's you know sexual preferences
uh are not something they can see as an
identifier that they aren't like
fulfilling if they don't vote a
particular way i'm not sure
uh but we certainly know that it's not a
coherent
structure of thought yeah i think that
seamus is right and i will interject
this here before
we move on a little bit we might read a
few more super chats here in a minute
no rush no worries we'll see how the
states are doing um
i i it really bothers me that the left
uses these
minority groups as pawns it truly
troubles me because i am
actually really compassionate like super
compassionate
like in a way that i don't think that
the leftists have ever been because i'm
like
why would you treat someone like a pond
when you treat them like a person
why is this complicated why should it be
complicated give me a break man
just treat us like humans i literally
filmed a video yesterday
um with a new york city uh a black cop
black police officer who lives in one of
the worst neighborhoods in new york city
um and he said exactly what you're
saying like like almost
identical right yeah you said they they
treat me you know
like a pawn like they expect me to think
a certain way and be a certain way to
act a certain way and he's like i
am pro-trump i'm pro-law enforcement
that's great of course he is like i live
in a bad neighborhood i see what happens
i have a daughter i got into law
enforcement to protect people i love
right i shouldn't be hated for that
exactly but it's also interesting how
anytime there is someone that goes
against the grain whether it's a black
person be conservative or any other like
minority
they not only attack that person they
attack them way more than they would if
it were just the traditional strategy
because i think it's more threatening i
think it is right because it can show
that there's not just this
there's strong models so i mean i think
there's a kind of contempt that they
view them with so this is something that
we saw
with people we would consider
working-class voters or white
working-class voters where this is a
group of people that democrats would
traditionally have said that they
stand for and buy but they're often
the butt of the joke especially when it
comes to conversations about trump and
so often we hear this impression of a
conservative and it always ends up being
some uneducated sounded pers
sounding person usually like a southern
accent yeah yeah
yeah exactly exactly uh
i thought that that was the case you
know and i i i met my first
conservatives and quotes my first
conservative friends in saint petersburg
in in florida and st pete that's so
great and they were gun-toting americans
but
yeah but i in the video i filmed with
them
he literally said i said do you hate gay
people
why would i yeah he goes no i want gay
people to have
guns to protect their their platform
exactly i heard that too
i love it okay so you're kind of liberal
then like yeah it's just new age
conservative that's right that's what
they call it i like
that new age conservative i like it yeah
so this also the conservative and this
is something i kind of take issue with
but
i think first and foremost it's possible
to disagree with somebody's lifestyle
choices
without hating them as a person but i
think that's definitely lost in the
modern conversation
yeah i think what's happened to
conservatism over the past several years
and it's something i've discussed on
this show and really
lamented is the fact that it sort of
changed from being something that i i
think was more
more uh deeply based in christianity and
in this country not necessarily
catholicism because america was sort of
founded on competing ideals usually
between like
maybe more liberal protestant thinkers
of the area and not anything really
robustly catholic but
we have changed uh the meaning of
conservative at least in america to sort
of being a loose affiliation of people
with kind of vaguely similar ideas about
the economy
and really no perspective on social
issues other than
a sort of run-of-the-mill classically
liberal perspective and
that's not a change that i'm fond of
ideologically but i wonder
if it's possible to win in this country
at this point without that
politically i don't know well there's a
difference between being right wing and
being conservative and i feel like we
don't
talk a lot about that right because
someone can be totally right-wing
economically but
be very liberal uh you know some people
might call it like oh well that's just a
libertarian it's like i know
that it's a little bit different and
versus you can actually have
like a democrat who's very socially
conservative right and for i think a lot
of catholics
that might be where they they find
themselves right because a lot of
catholics do vote democrat
unfortunately yeah but they are socially
conservative so i think there there's a
difference there and i think what we're
seeing is not necessarily a resurgence
of conservatism but more right-wing
populism
sure well no and that's exactly my point
like what the conservative movement in
america today is and has been is not
necessarily something
which i would consider conservative so i
don't really call it a resurgence of
conservatism
what's sad when it comes to the
catholics who vote democrat
for example this is something tim gave
me a shout out to about earlier
when he was on but joe biden for example
the media has repeatedly referred to joe
biden as a practicing catholic but by
definition he isn't because one of the
requirements
yeah one of the requirements in order to
be a practicing catholic is you have to
give full ascent to catholic teaching
calling teaching states that abortion is
murder and has to be treated as uh
such by civil authorities which joe
biden explicitly votes against
he's literally a civil authority exactly
yeah
and so what he's still referred to as a
a practicing council even though he's
been i think he has been denied
community he has been developing
he has been to my community now you
could say all right maybe there was some
priest who's out of line and denied a
community that wasn't the case the
priest was totally right to do so but
somebody could argue well one priest
isn't exactly um the standard bearer the
person who could tell us whether or not
he's catholic but
based on the actual definition of what a
practicing catholic is joe biden is not
one
yet how many catholics voted for him
some large number and
i think the catholic vote for i know
under obama the the catholic vote
uh the majority went to him which is
really sad
but also that's a result of the fact
that like most catholics just don't know
their faith very well
i mean i think to be fair to catholics
and like liam and i talk about this all
the time that's true of every faith
pretty much yeah it's
true unfortunately in the modern era i
would say that's pretty typical it's too
bad
one one thing that i just want to
interject is that the only gay person
here but like
i haven't used that card but i i had
this conversation with with sidney
lawton and a bunch of other
more conservative friends of mine and i
think that
one thing that the conservative movement
of the right leaning movement
has to do a better job at is welcoming
gay people because i think you're right
because
what do you mean by welcoming gay people
it's it's almost because we just
because i grew up in the 90s and the
republican party and just
majority of people didn't even accept
gay people you know gay marriage and and
not even obama until 2008 right
his second time so so it's still a
pressing issue
not in the law but in we're worried
about how other people see us still
well culturally believe it or not right
and i think for a lot of conservatives
um the whole thing comes down to uh i
think a lot of conservatives
see gay pride parades and equate that
lifestyle with every single lgbt person
which which is fair because that's what
they show but it's it's not actually
right it's definitely not it's
definitely not accurate let me say
something about pride parades
just because this is funny there's a
reason why lesbians lead the parade and
then you really don't see any lesbian
floats after that
yeah i don't know do you see any
lesbians that are naked ever like
nothing
don't remember that oh yeah they do the
dikes on bikes they're the first people
the first girls out and then
so yeah i guess when you say like the
conservative movement needs to be more
welcoming to gays like what does it mean
to welcome gays does that mean you have
to prove their lifestyle choices or that
you have to
that you you can no longer believe
marriages between a man and a woman or
does it just mean don't hate me don't
hurt me
how would you define this i would say
separation between
church and state for sure okay because
that that's just to me that's just an
american thing not not a conservative or
a liberal thing so would you say the
church and state are not separate if
marriage is defined as between a man and
a woman
as long as to me as long as i have the
same rights i wouldn't care what it's
called okay so
it's it's the same thing it's like
marriage is a piece of paper
yeah i i totally just we're not gonna
see eye to eye on this but i do totally
disagree
yeah honestly in which way uh i just i
believe marriage is so much more than a
piece of paper and i
part of this is just informed by i'm
talking about yeah yeah
yeah and the eyes of the law as long as
i don't care if it's called marriage
civil union whatever
as long as i have these same rights it's
it's the points
moot to me it's like it's it's the same
well what i've
found interesting is that i've also seen
a lot of conservatives say that they
don't like the idea of government
getting into marriage
at all absolutely yeah which is the
position that i take especially when we
look at the the taxation
the way that that works into as well as
things like granting special privileges
for things like estates and i think it's
it's a way for government to say we're
granting you special privileges for
marriage but really it's that
them justifying taking away privileges
from other people it's the way that i
see it so i don't think government
should be
like it doesn't really make sense if you
think of it like why would government
have a role in recognizing your personal
important relationship yeah i
don't i guess it is just a fundamental
disagreement on on what marriage is in
its role in society i would say that
when a man and woman come together
they're likely to be producing children
this all changed once the uh
the uh you know artificial contraception
became very popular
but historically it was the case and i
believe marriage is intended to be a
union where a man and woman produce
children or together for their entire
lives
i agree with that but why is the state
recognizing that sure because it's a
good thing for the state to incentivize
and it's good for the state to say if
you are married and you are the sole
provider for example even if you're not
the sole provider but you know you and
your wife are working or you're working
to support your wife and kids
we probably should tax you less because
you're going to be raising these
children but i want everybody
to be tax less and i want i agree too
yeah i want to abolish the income tax
i want everybody to be tax less and i am
in favor of things like
if you have like child tax credits and
even something like we've seen poland
and i
is it hungry or just poland it's hungry
yeah hungry yeah
in order to encourage birth rates but i
i don't necessarily see that as being
the same as saying like the government
needs to
define marriage especially when we i
don't know when we look at the fact that
so many people are getting married and
not having children it's looking like we
haven't we have if that
is the reason for government recognizing
marriage it's not looking like it's been
effective
yeah i mean nowadays people are
generally not having children i would
say that's more of a cultural issue than
a government issue but i do believe that
government recognizing marriage as it is
and wanting people to
have children or at least keep track of
who's having children is a good thing
but i suppose we disagree on this
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast we do the show
live
monday through friday at 8pm so come
back to check us out when we go live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for
free if you want to listen to us there
thanks for hanging out and we will see
you all
next time
you